it's time to see what's making the
headlines we're the editor of the
sheffield star nancy fielder and the pr
consultant alex dean they'll be with us
from now until just before midnight
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages the financial times leads
with us president joe biden's refusal to
extend america's withdrawal deadline
from afghanistan beyond one week from
now that is despite pleas from fellow g7
leaders including boris johnson
the metro has the same story their
headline joe's no to bojo
likewise the telegraph which shows
afghans boarding u.s military aircraft
the guardian says british troops could
leave kabul within 24 to 36 hours
but the express appears to contradict
that quoting the prime minister saying
that the airlift will continue until the
last moment
that places even more pressure on troops
to evacuate 4 000 more people before the
31st of august deadline as the times
reports
and the sun describes drama charlie
watts who died today as the rock behind
the stones
and we're joined tonight by nancy
fielder and alex dean evening to you and
now joe biden's statement in the white
house coming after the first editions of
the papers but widely briefed uh nancy
that he is sticking to that deadline of
august the 31st
so he has only just finished talking a
few minutes ago so no doubt lots of the
front pages will be updated but there
were no big shocks no big surprises
he's talked about the backup plans but
ultimately he has said that august 31st
is the end i mean he did kind of hint
that if it was a complete disaster i
think many of you would say it's already
been a complete disaster that it might
change but he looks to be sticking to
his guns on august 31st it is come what
may really
and alex as the president was speaking
an interesting phrase he used that we're
currently on pace to finish by
august the 31st i don't think anyone
believes that this is ever going to be
finished satisfactorily do they
no and we should be clear the reason
that this is not a surprise it's
disappointing but it's not a surprise
from the president is that the taliban
now controls the country and they've set
the timetable this is their deadline
their red line
and he's complying with it and therefore
it looks like the rest of the
international community is likely to as
well and someone may say that's just
real polity but it is desperately sad
for the people of afghanistan and for
the world that this repressive regime
can exercise that power over these
people but i thought it was a really
interesting press conference as well i'm
worth just taking a moment to reflect on
the fact that the president's passion i
thought was very clear the majority of
his remarks and much of what he said in
the three courses of the beginning of it
was spent on domestic affairs was spent
on his domestic agenda the american
economy and his plan for america as to
be navigated through congress all well
and good but i think it really shows
where his focus lies and i show i think
it shows very much where the
administration wants to spend its time
in some ways they think afghanistan's
already behind them and finally of
course he took once again no questions
from the world's press if that was a
president on the right of the political
center i think people would be going mad
because it's joe biden people seem to be
willing to put up with it but there's
there's got to come a time which the
media says why aren't you taking
questions from people why aren't you
willing to interact so i think that was
a very interesting conference but for a
lot of the wrong reasons yeah i mean a
focus on the domestic agenda meanwhile
only one in four americans uh think he
is doing the right thing and handling
his withdrawal from afghanistan in the
correct manner let's have a look at the
telegraph uh nancy at same headline
there biden refuses to extend the
deadline at the photograph there of
those who are managing
to get out of afghanistan before that
deadline meanwhile as we've seen in
stuart ramsey's report tonight others
are waiting
with fading hopes in in a sewage ditch
absolutely and there are thousands and
thousands of them and as we know the
taliban has already said that afghans
should not be leaving they they are
reasonably accepting that other troops
need to get out and that foreigners need
to get out but they're not letting all
those tens of thousands of people who
supported what the west were trying to
do
get out and we all suspect we know that
most of them will be executed in fact
we're hearing rumors that things like
that are already happening i mean these
are look at the size of that little boy
they are just tiny people they they're
just being left behind to absolutely
devastating consequences i think it's
breaking so many hearts and i don't
think that any politician that alone the
president of the united states should be
allowed to not answer questions just to
be allowed to say he thinks it's behind
him because obviously the home agenda is
important but this situation has been
primarily caused by actions that have
been going on for a long time and to
wash our hands of it and say we'll try
and get our own people out but everybody
else just gets stuck it's absolutely
despicable
alex this is portrayed as biden's
refusal but was it his decision to make
ultimately at this point because the
taliban are running the show here
yes but they came to run the show as i
said in the earlier answer they came to
on the show because the president had
made an absolute all-out commitment to
leave the country by a certain date but
once you've done that you've basically
invited your opponents to push you go
further and conceded that you're going
to leave the pitch actually there were
very few i don't mean to be flippant
about mortality i don't mean to be
flipping about military deaths but the
level of fatalities and casualties
amongst military personnel in the in
afghanistan whether it be united states
or other uh service personnel was
extremely low in in the last couple of
years it was a stable circumstance a
stable situation that was pretty much
guaranteed by their mere presence by
their assistance for afghan military as
advisers and crucially air support so
the americans weren't suffering uh
losses in the way that they they indeed
we suffered in the earlier days of
afghanistan but instead when the
president said he was going to leave he
invited the taliban to take over
effectively and that's the point he
could well have changed course he could
well have changed direction when it
became clear that this is the way that
it was going to go
now you've got to respect joe biden's
consistency he's always wanted to come
out he was then he was a skeptic under
president obama when he was vice
president but that being consistent for
a long time doesn't mean that you're
right and i'm afraid in these
circumstances a great deal of
responsibility does rest on the
president and it was very clearly his
call the buck stops here it impresses a
lot of responsibility rests on him for
what is now happening and a lot of it is
terrible alex looking at the metro
though what about the prime minister
boris johnson is this a failure by him
uh to persuade uh president biden to
extend that withdrawal
well i respect his attempts to do so um
but yes plainly it hasn't worked i mean
i i've one's got to applaud whatever
yours you think about prime minister
you're desperately trying to get the
american president to do what you or i
might right think is the right thing and
you know it's honorable failure isn't it
even uh if you fail at least he tried
and i must say about our prime minister
that on this i think he's um his hands
are slightly tied because it's become
very clear that our activity in that
environment and in that arena is at
least as far as our experts tell us very
dependent upon the americans and the
lead the americans take we're going to
have to think a great deal about what
that means for our activity going
forward in uh regional wars and
conflicts and peacekeeping missions like
this going forward but of course we had
mounted a very significant withdrawal
from afghanistan anyway so for us it was
natural that we're going to be dependent
upon the americans until we wound up
putting troops back in which people are
now trying to hang on and hang on to
airports and so forth it was natural
that was going to happen because the
americans were taking the lead now we've
got to ask ourselves do the americans
lead anymore and nancy let's just have a
quick look at the garden yeah let me
bring you in on that
it means a little bit too late so today
the prime minister may have tried to
persuade the american president but
we've known about this withdrawal we've
been in that country for two decades and
we've made a right or mess of it so to
say that he's tried desperately hard
well quite frankly it was too late and
he only did it after it was clear that
public opinion was massive massively
against this and the tv and news crews
were just showing absolutely hideous
images so i think it's far too little
too late and i haven't got much respect
for either what we've done or what the
us has done to be honest
why were we not acting why did we not
make better decisions than this two
months ago nancy the reason the
difference that i would point to is that
when the facts changed our prime
minister changed his mind he wanted at
least a few more days when the facts
changed the american president didn't
change his that's the difference
deaths not just from coronavirus nancy
but other causes
absolutely well we've seen the news
today that um we have got the highest
death figures since march and that this
virus is not going anywhere not
surprising to anybody um but actually
as has been indicated for quite a long
time now there's some other issues that
haven't been dealt with because of the
backlog of cases because of the huge
amount of nhs resources need to attack
needed to tackle covid those death
figures are rising too so all in all a
pretty miserable situation but the
message is the nhs is open and if you
think you need to be checked out please
go and get checked out open but under
increasing strain uh staff within the
nhs really
bearing this burden alex
well we were told for a long time that
if we suggested that the coronavirus
measures would lead to harm in other
patients that we were um we were
scaremongering or spreading conspiracy
theories well here we have to this
week's death totals which show more than
10 000 people died in a week but 544 of
them were from coronavirus the vast
majority from something else and as the
public health england figures show here
heart disease diabetes cirrhosis all
being under treated um in the current
environment and heaven knows what the
cancer statistics will look like when we
get to those we turned our nhs into a
coronavirus healthcare system but for a
while we've got to get back to treating
all kinds of conditions as much as
possible
let's have a look at the sun and its
front page nancy is paying tribute to
charlie watts the drummer from the
rolling stones who's died at the age of
80. the rock behind the stones
absolutely and what comes across from
all the coverage of his very sad death
it's just what a lovely bloke he was and
he really seems to be in the glue that
held the band together and he had so
many other interests and passions other
types of music beyond what is so well
known for the rock and roll and i just
think that it comes across as genuinely
really nice and so many so many big
names are absolutely devastated they're
lost today he was known to be poorly but
i don't think they realized quite how
poorly it was so many people have said
today in the tributes
and he was a reluctant rock star wasn't
he a jazz man in a in a rock and roll
band alex
yeah but still an icon like from the
first chords of saint of me uh at all
you'll start me up you get that shiver
at the back of the the neck and you
think this is going to be a great number
i so regret not seeing the stones uh
live when he was alive and he was a
great great musician it's a really sad
bit of news
yeah
um he also didn't like the limelight um
as much as many of his band mates he
said i don't like drum solos i admire
people that do them but generally i
prefer drummers playing with the bands
he was the steady beat
within the rolling stones
that's right but then when mick jagger
referred to him as my drummer he
famously of course punched him and said
you're my singer you know he wasn't shy
about the role of the drummer he didn't
think he was going to be put down either
after putting on his uh suit yeah
yeah always dapper and that's the other
thing that is that has come out in all
of the tributes that have been paid to
him nancy isn't it a man of immense
style in his savile row suit and tie
absolutely if you look at the photos
from the most recent ones to the really
early days ones it just looks fantastic
doesn't it always put the effort in and
he might not have thought that the
drummers needed to take the solos but he
was
definitely one of the greatest drummers
that we have ever seen and i have no
doubt that his influence will continue